I was born in a Christian family.
I was raised in a Christian way.
I think Islam is a lie.
because that's something I used to say.
Islam is a lie.
the Quran is poison.
already thought, okay,
these Muslim guys are kind of crazy.
and this religion isn't the truth.
so it wasn't my eyes that were blind.
it was really my heart.
I couldn't accept it.
I think my nuffs or my neffs or whatever. my ego.
and I decided to write an anti Islam book
which started as an anti Islam book
changed into this search for God
and it ended up me becoming a Muslim.
so I thought to myself, okay,
this is going the wrong direction.
his life was the Quran.
he was the living Quran in a way.
just studied it sooner.
and I think that is the best way of discovering Islam.
I couldn't sleep for it for 2 days.
I couldn't accept it.
it was so, so strange.
and that made me feel very happy.